字幕: Mimi Uzura
校正: Emi Atarashi
みなさん
アイスクリームは好きですか？
逆にアイスクリーム
嫌いな人 いますか?
みんな大好きですよね
僕も アイスクリーム
大好きなんです
このおいしそうな写真のアイス
実は 牛乳も卵も使わずに
植物性の材料だけで作った
「豆乳アイス」なんです
僕が妻と２人で作ってます
この写真の 私の隣にいる
かわいい女性が 妻のマーシーです
この美味しそうなバーガーも
これも
この可愛いチーズケーキも
全部 動物を使わずに作られた
植物性の食べ物です
最近では 研究室で培養された
動物を殺さないお肉なんてのも
ニュースになってましたね
こういった 研究者とか 生産者とか
消費者たちの努力によって
世界は少しずつ
グリーンに変わってきています
このグラフ
UKの１人あたりの
お肉の消費量の推移です
見ての通り
右肩下がりですよね
UKにおいて
この10年で なんと
１人あたりのお肉の消費量は
17％も減りました
ヴィーガン、ベジタリアンの数は
２倍以上増え
人口の５％程度だと
発表されました
すごいですよね
世界が変わって行っていることを
実感できた瞬間でした
私もUKには３年ほど
住んでいたんですが
あれほど ヴィーガンフレンドリーな国には
今のところ行ったことがありません
では 次に
世界全体を見てみましょう
こちらのグラフを見てみてください
この一直線に増加しているもの
これは世界全体での
お肉の消費量の推移です
私たちは この50年で
４倍ものお肉を
消費するようになりました
ちなみに日本では
この50年で
１人当たり 10倍ものお肉を
食べるようになりました
今の時点で
畜産が排出する温室効果ガスは
総量の15％にもなります
これは 地球上に走っている
すべての家庭用自動車が
排出する量に匹敵するんです
今後 自動車が排出する温室効果ガスの量は
減るって予想されてるので
肉食が 車よりも
深刻な環境破壊の原因になる日は
もう すぐそこにあるんです
僕らは まだまだ
何にもできてないんです
じゃあ 僕らにいったい
何ができるんでしょうか
「今日から皆でヴィーガンになりましょう」
って言っても
そんな簡単には できませんよね
私も 実は
完全なヴィーガンではありません
では 先ほどのUKのデータを
もう一度 見てみましょう
10年で 約17％
１人当たりのお肉の消費量は減りました
ベジタリアン、ヴィーガンの総人口は
約３％増えました
つまり 彼らのおかげで
お肉の消費量は３％ぐらい減ったわけですよね
では 消費が減った分の残りの
この14％は
どこから来たんでしょうか
答えは 簡単ですよね
ヴィーガン、ベジタリアンではない人が
お肉を食べる量を減らしたんです
例えば 世界で
この14％を減らすことができれば
世界中の全ての飛行機を止めるのと
同じだけのインパクトを
得られるんです
そして この14％は
７分の１
ちょうど１週間のうちの
１日に相当します
１週間のうち１日だけ
菜食を選ぶだけで
飛行機を一切使わない生活に
相当するんです
ただ この想像を実現するためには
１つだけ問題があります
それは ここにいる全ての人の協力が
必要だということなんです
でも 実現できれば
世界が変わるんです
僕は４年前まで
ヨーロッパに住んでまして
ポーランドでは 妻と
ヴィーガンのレストランを開店しました
お店は大盛況で
お持ち帰りメインのお店に
毎日300人以上が訪れるような
お店になりました
では なぜ私たちのヴィーガンレストランは
成功できたんでしょうか
写真を見たら分かりますよね
若い頃の僕が
ハンサムだったからです
というのは冗談で
本当の理由は
お客様のほとんどが
ヴィーガンではない方だったからなんです
お店でよくあったんですが
入ってきたお客さんが メニューを見て
「セイタンソーセージ」という商品を頼むんです
たぶん 菜食に興味のある人でないと
わからないんですが
セイタンソーセージは
セイタンという麦から採れるタンパク質で作った
「ソーセージもどき」なんです
ヴィーガンレストランに 本物のソーセージが
売ってあるはずがないんですが
とにかく 明らかに そのお客さまは
そのことに気づいてないんです
もしかすると
ヴィーガンレストランだってことにすら
気づいていないのかもしれません
しょうがなく説明すると
ほとんどの人は
「まぁ 一度試してみるか」と
購入してくれます
そして 次の日に またやって来て
セイタンソーセージを注文してくれるんです
「ヴィーガンになる」ってことは
できなくても
比較的気楽に ヴィーガンという選択肢を
選ぶことはできるんです
しかも 実は すっごくおいしいんです
そこで気がつきました
世界を変えるためには
すでにヴィーガンになった人のために
商品を売っても
しょうがないんじゃないかって
今 ヴィーガンじゃない人にこそ
選んでもらわなければ
いけないのではないかって
約５％の人が
ヴィーガン、ベジタリアンだとすると
その５％の人たちは
よりグリーンな生き方へ
すでに移行してしまった人たちなんです
逆に言うと
私たちのような
残りの95％の人こそが
世界を変えられるんです
もちろん
植物性の選択肢を選びやすい
環境づくりっていうのは 大切な要素です
UKでは それができていたからこそ
お肉の消費量を減らせたんです
私は 15年前に
ヴィーガンになることを決意しました
それからの僕の夕ごはんは
コンビニで買う
ポテチのうすしお味の
大容量パックでした
好んでポテチを
夕飯にしていたわけじゃなくて
コンビニで買えるヴィーガン対応の食品は
ポテチのうすしお味ぐらいしか
なかったんです
15年前に 日本で 時間のない若者が
ヴィーガンになるっていうのは
こういうことでした
そして 残念ながら15年経った今でも
状況は ほとんど変わっていません
最近 スーパーでよく見るー
「お肉を使わない新しい選択」
って書かれた代替肉商品には
なんと ビーフエキスと
ゼラチンが入っていました
欧米のいくつかの国を除いて
「菜食」っていう考え方は
とっても取り入れづらいのが
いまだに現実なんです
じゃあ いったいどうやって
週に１回 菜食を選ぶんだよって
なっちゃいますよね
その状況を変えるために
「小さなヴィーガンビジネス」が活躍するんです
４年前に 日本に帰国して始めた
豆乳アイスのビジネスですが
今では各地のスーパーで
お取り扱い頂いております
そんないくつかのスーパーでは
私たちの豆乳アイスが
「ヴィーガン」って記載された
初めての商品だったんです
世界が少し変わった瞬間でした
想像してみてください
そのスーパーに行く人にとって
豆乳アイスという植物性の選択肢は
知りもしないし 選ぶこともできない
裏メニューだったんです
でも 今は 目の前にある
普通の選択肢の１つになったんです
どちらの例でも 同じなんですが
ここまで来るのに大切なのは
「この商品を購入してくれる人がいた」
っていうことなんです
例えば お客さまが
私たちの豆乳アイスを選ぶことで
世界が変わったんです
また 小さなヴィーガンビジネスは
予想以上に大きなインパクトを
世界に与えてくれます
あなたがヴィーガンになることで
植物性に変えられる消費は
１人分ですよね
でも 例えば１年に
５万個のアイスを売れば
その消費が与えるインパクトは
もっともっと大きなものになります
「５万個のアイス」っていうのは
「あなたの人生２回分のおやつ」に
相当しちゃうんです
しかも たったの１年で
それだけのインパクトを
得ることができるんです
もし あなたが ヴィーガンビジネスの
お客さまだったとすれば
あなたが彼らに支払った商品代金は
また違う植物性の商品の
購入のために使われるはずですよね
あなたのたった１回の選択が
何倍もの植物性の選択に変わるんです
あなたが選べるのは
食べ物だけじゃないんです
このカラフルでかわいい写真
子どものために
割れにくいこのカップに入れたんですが
これ プラスチックじゃないんです
「竹」 バンブーの繊維からできた
植物性のカップなんです
こんな選択もあるんです
私には３歳になる娘が１人います
妻と並んで
世界で１番かわいい女の子なんですが
自分が この２年間
コロナウイルスのおかげで
やりたいことができない世界を
体験して思うんです
僕らがやりたい放題して
選択の自由を満喫するおかげで
僕らの子どもたちやその子どもたちが
したいこともできない人生を
送るハメになるんじゃないかなって思うんです
だから せめて
自分にできることをやって
笑顔でバトンを渡したいんです
この人類最大の危機と戦うことは
ヴィーガンにならなくてもできます
でも ここにいるすべての人の協力が
必要不可欠なんです
もう「ヴィーガン、ヴィーガン」って
いろいろなところで聞くし
もう 嫌気がさしている人も
いるんじゃないでしょうか
でも 現実を見てください
私たちは まだまだ
何にもできてないんです
あなたがたまに選ぶその植物性の選択は
とってもポジティブな選択なんです
きっと ちょっとカロリー控えめで
ヘルシーで
ついでに
温室効果ガスも減らせて
動物も笑顔で
未来の子どもたちまで笑顔になっちゃう
そんなハッピーな選択肢なんです
そして
その選択はあなたをー
そして世界を変えるんです